this is the jocko unraveling podcast
episode seven
with daryl cooper and me jocko willink
let's
go ahead and follow the thread
so where we at we left everybody hanging
last time um we cut it off right as you
were about to kick it off in ramadi
and um
i mean i think this is there's so much
stuff i want to talk about in this one
um
we you know we could start off talking
about
these the stakes at play in ramadi how
there were so many people on the
domestic side that were saying this war
is lost people even in the military who
were saying this this thing is over
anbar at least is done
um
there were people all along
from petraeus up north of mosul at the
beginning with the 101st other people in
talafar mcmaster and so forth who were
saying this thing can be won but they
you got to change your mentality and so
when you get to ramadi um you mentioned
that you picked up the
counter-insurgency manual and i don't
know where you got it because it wasn't
it wasn't published until december of
06. it was not yet but i i got the
latest copy on the internet yeah it was
a draft copy and that's i mean on the
not on notice i said internet not on the
sippernet it wasn't on the classified
side it was a draft copy
that i got and i just went and google
searched it and they had just put it out
there it's kind of like
the
the marine corps just released a
document
called learning and it's the first one
that's been released in 20 something
years well since 2001
and
you know the draft of that document you
know you could find it
way earlier than when it was actually
released
so yeah that that um
and this is in april so when did you say
it actually got formally released
december yeah
yeah i had you must have been one of the
early adopters for sure i was definitely
an early adopter i i i know that i was
the first person that i knew that had
read it was me like i didn't meet
anybody else that said oh yeah here's
the new manual
and it was weird for me too to like dive
into a manual and just say okay i gotta
have an open mind here looking at this
but seeing
again seeing the the
hey here we're all going after all these
bad guys but it doesn't really seem to
have a long-term sustaining impact
because it's been three years of us
doing this
made me say we've got to look some other
way there's got to be some other way
that this is unfolding for sure
what did you get out of it because i
mean you just sat down and read the
thing basically straight through right
yeah i sat down and read the thing
straight through
and i'll tell you what i got well i'll
tell you i'll tell you the ma one of the
main things that i stole from it
was security for the populace
and that's the first thing that kind of
made sense to me i said okay
right how do we provide security for the
populace which is different than i'm
going to remove people right i'm going
to take bad guys
providing security for the populace and
the idea that the decisive
the decisive element in this war was not
an airfield it was not a mountaintop it
was not a beachhead
the decisive
the decisive terrain in this war
was the people and i'm gonna say it was
the hearts and minds of the local
populace so that was the main takeaway
for me
and then you know you just read through
it and you realize
that
in order to do the kind of
the kind of when you think of
counter-insurgency well at least at the
time i think a lot of people when they
thought of counter insurgency what they
thought of was hearts and minds which is
hey we're gonna go we're gonna build
schools we're gonna give away food we're
gonna we're gonna give medcaps you know
and and go out and help people medically
and it sounds so hunky-dory and you
think well
that sounds great but then you look at
ramadi and you go how can this possibly
happen here
and
in the counter-insurgency manual it
explains that in order for those things
to take place you you have to have
control over the battlefield and we
didn't have control yet so the first
step in counterinsurgency is you got to
get some kind of control
in that situation so that's another
thing i realized and the fact that
and this was i think petraeus said this
later he paraphrased it later and it
made
sense and i don't know
i got the idea i understood it from the
counterinsurgency manual even though i
don't think these words are actually in
there but he said this can't be a
drive-by counter insurgency meaning hey
you can't just drive into a neighborhood
say hi and then leave you got to go in
there and you got to stay so that made a
lot of sense to me so there was some
some things that i just had to open my
mind and see in a different light and
seeing that target board and knowing
that
for lack of a better way of saying this
we were losing
and a lot of this comes back again to
the book about face by david hackworth
because
he's the guy that said we're losing like
in vietnam he's the first kind of
legitimate guy that said we're losing
and it wasn't that i don't know if the
thought we're losing would have entered
my mind had i not read that book
but
a i'd read that book and i read that
book a lot but b as you just said
there was
the populist in america was turning
against the war this is 2006
this is nasty and there's no end in
sight and there's americans coming home
you know in caskets all the time
and
so so we've got
much of the american popular saying hey
we've had enough of this we've got
government officials saying we're not
going to win you know it's an election
year it's an election year it's just
nasty yeah
so the fact that i
had a little bit of you know i have a
natural rebellious streak in me
and that's very beneficial sometimes
from a leadership position because
you're questioning what's happening as
opposed to just accepting what's
happening
so for me to say
for me to question what we were doing
and how we were doing it was very good
and very lucky and also
from a leadership perspective i'm coming
in there i'm detached right i hadn't
been to iraq in two years so i'm i'm i'm
detached from it
guys that are in the fight they're in
the fight they're worried about the the
op they're doing tonight tomorrow night
that's what they're worried about they
got a bad guy good they're planning for
another op they're not even looking at
where it goes
i'm coming in it from a de facto
detached position where i'm looking at
it from 30 000 feet going
so i come from the states where
everyone's saying well not everyone but
where a lot of people are saying we're
losing we can't win i show up there i
see this target board it looks like
we're not making any progress
i think think we've got to do something
different and that cracks me into the
the counter insurgency manual three what
is it three tech 24 that's the new one
yeah
the
insurgents it took us a while to
understand counter insurgency the
insurgents understood their part of it
real well
talk about how we need to go and we need
to build a school we need to open a pump
station or whatever
they knew that they needed to go blow up
the ribbon cutting
us troops would be out there giving
candy to iraqi kids and they would drive
a suicide bomb into the crowd of kids
and
after a while we realized none of this
stuff that we're doing matters if we
can't provide security for the security
for the puppets you know there's
something that you said on the last
podcast and i re-listened to it and it's
funny because
you said something along the lines of
the insurgents realized that they had
they they realized i think you said a
weapon or
but you ended up saying they had they
they knew what they needed they knew
what they had on their side and i
thought what they needed to get on their
side or something like that and i
thought you were gonna you said you said
people yeah right and what i thought you
were gonna say was time because that
really is the ultimate weapon of an
insurgency is look
you hey hey american hey gringo you want
to stay here and you know lose
you know 10 guys a week or 20 guys a
week
cool we'll be here we can we can outlast
you and we we don't want to go home we
are home you know are you americans you
want to go home i don't care what
american you are you want to go home we
don't want to go home we are home and so
we can outlast you and and that's that
really is time is the ultimate weapon
and an insurgency that's another thing
and i remember here's a good
conversation i had so this was pressing
into
combat actually starting in
in ramadi this is something i completely
took from the counterinsurgency manual
so we started doing these overwatch
operations where we were going out and
providing security for the populace via
killing bad guys and
so we started conducting these
operations this was this there's a
couple things that got from the counter
surgery
number one when you start a counter
insurgency enemy activity is not going
to go down it's going to go up friendly
casualties are not going to go down they
are going to go up so so right there
right there it already feels wrong when
you start a counter insurgency it feels
wrong and it looked looks wrong
so the the people that are tracking
sig axe which is a term for significant
activity which which which was a word
that had its own
meaning in its own life you know how
many sig acts were there today meaning
how many enemy activities enemy attacks
were there and the
that would get tracked it was a metric
and so when we started this counter
insurgency guess what happens to the
enemy attacks the enemy contacts they go
up what happens to the us casualties
they go up
so
probably three weeks into this
we had conducted maybe
overwatch operations probably killed x
amount of guys i don't know x amount of
enemy 10 20.
and i get a
uh uh an email from
like one of the guys up the chain of
command it was it wasn't my commanding
officer was someone up the chain of
command for me
and it was something along the lines of
hey
here you are conducting these operations
to take out ied emplacers and insurgents
and we're actually seeing an increase in
enemy activity wha what metrics are you
going off of that makes you think that
this is even remotely effective
and why i just said it a little bit more
hostile wasn't as hostile as that but
from the counter-insurgency manual that
i had read
i replied hey appreciate the feedback
the average insurgency lasts seven years
it's been three weeks can i get some
more time to measure the metrics and and
they were like okay you know fair enough
but that was
me having read this book and
and and pulled things out of it that
were actually completely accurate to
what we were living
so those watching those sick acts go up
was was rough
and i remember the the brigade commander
colonel sean mcfarland you know he was
answering the mail on this kind of thing
and we'd be sitting in a brigade meeting
and he'd say yeah the division
is looking at us saying hey
how how are we supposed to think you're
doing a good job here
when enemy activity is increasing and
you know he probably gave a similar
answer to what i did we're taking the
fight to the enemy and there's going to
be there's going to be casualties
there's going to be blood but that's the
that's the pathway to victory when the
people become the ground that you're
trying to win
as opposed to an airfield or something
like that and a counter insurgency that
means that
everything you do has got to be measured
for for lack of a better term political
effect as well as like tactical effect
right
and
this is why this battle
it just has fascinated me for a long
time because taking what i just said
about everything you do has got to be
measured for political effect
and you guys are going into a city that
probably much of it hasn't seen an
american
who was sort of holding their ground in
a year maybe in some of these places
and you're going into a sunni city
with
iraqi security forces that are mostly if
not all shia right
you've got to convince those shia
soldiers to treat the sunni civilians
that they're going to be encountering
with respect yup you've got to tr you've
got to convince the sunni populist there
that hey we're coming in here with this
is
just for everybody else out there if you
don't remember what 2006 was like
the very very beginning of the year
al-qaeda in iraq
massive car bomb at the samara mosque
which is like one of the holiest sites
in the entire shia world and the shia
went insane they're burning down sunni
mosques their
you know sectarian cleansing baghdad
neighborhoods running sunnis out and
it's at a point where the shia militias
have you know totally infiltrated a lot
of the iraqi police people are getting
arrested by the iraqi police and two
days later their families get a phone
call from the shia militia that now has
that person and they're demanding ransom
and so you're bringing shia soldiers
into this sunni city that hasn't seen an
american has no reason to trust us at
all
in a long time and you've got to
convince both of those sides to play
nice that nobody's doing anything here
we're in control
and when you guys start talking to the
tribes which is really what i'm super
interested in hearing about how you guys
approach this you know in 2005 just
another aspect of like the political
side of this
um and by that i just mean inner group
you know group interaction uh the tribes
had tried to unite and fight against al
qaeda back in 2005 and they got
annihilated and all their leaders
branded jordan and everywhere else the
leaders ran to jordan the ones that
survived because i want to say there was
a 24-hour period or 48-hour period where
eight of the tribal leaders were killed
eight of them yeah so i mean that's
that's like saying you know if you
picture the the uh
new york crime families in the in the
60s right saying that oh yeah all the
heads of the families got killed that
that's that's what and then the ones
that were left yeah they they ran and
they were junior too i mean a lot of
them were younger right
because a lot of people got killed and
people got kind of yes some people
bumped up some people fled some people
just um faded
yeah all those things happened you had
the glass factory i think in february of
06 january of
january
january of 06 there's a there's a police
recruiting
drive let's call it a recruiting drive
for
the young iraqi men to come and join the
iraqi police where they can now get
control of their city
there's a massive suicide bomb there
there was a guy by the name of
lieutenant colonel mccaul mclaughlin
who had was apparently and he would this
happened before i got there so i didn't
know him but he was with the 228 out of
pennsylvania so he's a reservist
they called the they called him the
shake of shakes because he was you know
just a great guy that had this great
attitude that was trying to make things
happen and got along with all the
different shakes and understood what we
were trying to make happen
so he's actually and this is what proves
what kind of a leader he was you know
this is a risky operation to have this
big recruiting drive but they set
security up and now they have
several hundred
young iraqi men that are thinking okay
well it looks like we're gonna take back
our city from these insurgents you know
and and and my shake and some of the
other shakes have said to come down here
and and join up with this iraqi police
and the glass factory is an old glass
factory and it's right outside of camp
ramadi so it's a good place to do it
camp ramadi being an all-american you
know um base with thousands of troops on
there and a lot of firepower the glass
factories just outside
so they run this recruiting meeting um
and
the suicide bomber
there's
55 or 60 of the recruits are killed
mclaughlin
mclaughlin is killed a marine that was
on
security
adam cann sergeant adam kan he was on
security he was also killed there's
another
55 or 60
iraqis friendly iraqis that were there
to get recruited that were wounded so i
mean you picture what the just just
imagine that
you're a young kid
you show up we're going to take back
ramadi you show up the americans are
providing security the americans are
going to make everything nice again the
americans are aligned with my shake my
shake has sent me down here
and then the insurgents kill
everyone that you know and wound
everyone else and if you made it out of
their unscathed you were never going to
think about doing anything like that
again as far as you could you could tell
this is a couple months before you guys
got there and started this this is in
january yep this is in january about 6.
so just all of those challenges stacked
on top of each other you know convincing
the sunni that a we're going to protect
you from okay you know let me interject
hold on
so
one thing when you were talking about
the shias the shia
soldiers
and some of them i mean who
what's the what's the profile of someone
that joins the she the the iraqi army in
2006 what's that profile look like well
yes guess what it's a it's a lower class
person we're talking about the front
line grunts because there's there's the
whole officer thing and it's a it's just
like any well it's not it's it's the
officer thing where these guys pay to
get in position they come from a family
or whatever but the
the the soldiers
who joins the iraqi army in 2006 who's
who's a shield yep they're they're shia
they need money they're not educated
they
are looking for a job
and here you go
that's the same exact profile of who is
joining the
the mahdi army to go and fight for the
shias you know kind of
that's the exact it's the exact same
profile so
in the barracks room
of so leif leif babin who was one of the
platoon commanders
he was running a troop of of iraqi
soldiers
in their barracks on the american base
they had a giant poster on the wall of
muktara al-sadr
on their wall in the clear like hey
we're we're here to fight and yeah
that's a picture of muktara soder you
know the sort of most
vocal and rebellious leader of the shia
sect at this point so that's
what that's what you're looking at it's
crazy and the the picture i've tried to
find it
you've seen them picture the picture of
muktad al-sadr with his kind of finger
raised up and
i mean he's a very he's a very he's a
caricature right he's he fits the exact
uh image of what you would expect this
fiery guy charismatic guy cr you know
he's got like a little crazy eyes to him
he fits that exact image and so they got
this giant poster in it it has like
lightning around it
so that's what that that's what we do
much for subtlety in the middle east
that's what we're dealing with one of my
one of my favorite things ever is uh one
of the insurgent groups that's been
operating out in iraq or they were until
a year or two ago
called themselves euphrates volcano i'm
like that's awesome yeah yeah wait we're
not sure if we're not i'm giving you
guys slack for a couple beheadings for
that good name we're not sure if we're
uh like a a roller derby team
or an insurgent group but we're we're
feeling it yeah having that that poster
up there points to i mean another one
right so you've got to get the sunni and
shia to play nice together you've got to
convince the sunni in the city that we
can protect you from al qaeda after we
haven't done that at all for years now
and al qaeda has been the law of the
land as long as you've been here
and when we recently failed to protect
you you know with the glass factory
attack uh but another one uh is that
you've got to convince i imagine it
wasn't hard
with your guys maybe but um do you have
any issues where when you started to
talk to the tribes
um with americans or like these guys
were shooting at us last year and you
want us to give them amnesty work with
them or these guys got a poster of
muktara sutter and their barracks and
we're supposed to trust these guys like
how was that are you talking about me
with the seals in task unit bruiser i
would i would imagine that wasn't a
problem
the it was a little the hardest
challenge with the seals and tasking the
bruiser was hey guys we're going to be
working with iraqi soldiers pretty much
all the time are they going to watch our
back are they going to watch our back
can we trust them and the answer is no
and no so what do you do you mitigate
risk you figure out how you can train
them up enough you figure out what how
you operate with them where you're
you've got four of those guys that are
supposed to be doing something and you
need two seals there to make sure that
they're doing what they're supposed to
be doing so this was really before
there hadn't been a lot of of
you know um
they end up calling it green on green on
blue meaning a a bad like a like an
iraqi soldier turns and starts shooting
that happened more in afghanistan it
happened some in iraq but at this point
it wasn't a huge threat we thought about
it of course
like you just don't feel comfortable
when you've got a guy that's got a
poster of muktad al-sadr in his bedroom
and now he's standing next to you with
an ak-47
uh you know there's there's definitely
some trust issues and then there was
different types of guys you know if
there there's
there's kurdish some kurdish soldiers
that would be in some of these units and
they would be very trustworthy and very
squared away but like almost a different
different level
actually they they were straight up at
different levels so if you had a couple
kurdish guys you'd be pretty stoked on
that
but yeah it was it was so so as far as
telling my guys we're going to use
when you're working with iraqis
that was a little bit of a struggle but
then when they understood why we're
doing it
then they realized okay and and even if
even if they didn't agree with
why we were doing it because the the
what i told them was hey
we either get them
up to speed where they can handle
security in their own country or we're
going to be here forever and we're going
lose
or we can get these guys trained up get
them out there so they can handle
security and then we're good if that
didn't convince my guys here's the other
half of it and this is the this is the
slam dunk for a seal
by the way
we have two choices we either take
iraqis with us or we don't work
who wants to work
you know they'll you know seals want to
work and they want to get after it and
if that means we got to take iraqi
soldiers cool we'll take iraqi soldiers
so i probably got there i probably got
you know their hearts
60 there just talking about the big
strategic picture but you got to tie it
back to why it's good for them and
what's good for a seal is i get to go
out and kill bad guys and so
hey this is what this is what's going to
allow us to do that
okay cool we're on board let's make it
happen were you guys operating pretty
much from the moment you got there yeah
i mean they had missions for you and
ready to go
when you say they had missions for us we
had we developed missions so the task
that we turned over with you know they
were tracking targets we picked up some
of those targets and
within
we were doing operations very quickly
when did the
you know i mean when did the actual
operation to take the city back really
start where you start setting up the
cops around the city and really pushing
so there was a there was like june or so
maybe but there was a there was a
i guess i would might call it a false
start
which was
when we got there
the first briefs that i gave my guys
were hey we're going to go we're going
to do a fallujah on this we're going to
do what they did in fallujah we're going
to do here because that's kind of where
the planning was at the 228 had done a
great job surrounding the city and now
you've got both
the 228 and the 118d on station for
turnover and that means we've got double
the combat power that means we're going
to go through the city and crush it
maliki to his credit who had just been
elected prime minister as a shia
said
hey if he knew what would happen if if
he directed that to happen it would be
all the sunnis saying look at what the
shia is doing to us they're killing us
and it would have caused a problem he
said you need to figure out another way
to do it a less kinetic way of doing it
that's the word we got we actually got
the word
so we had we were planning massive
massive multi
multi battalion operations
so the word comes down
actually we were in the process of
planning a battalion sized operation
we were going to support the first of
the
506. and the
you know real quick this is fascinating
because it's been written up in articles
and i think even in tom rick's book
um
that
that this was done intentionally that it
was a head fake that we loaded up a
whole bunch of
metamaterial like we were going to come
in like fallujah in order to get some of
the insurgents that had been nested in
the city to back out before we started
moving into neighborhoods but we were
actually planning on doing that it
sounds like if that was the head fake
then they faked me out too okay and they
faked out everybody that i talked to and
worked with
including up to and including
planning a battalion-sized operation
that we were going to execute so if it
was a head fake effect it had faked the
brigade commander and the battalion
commanders as well because we were all
ready to execute that
we get the word we're planning a
battalion-sized operation we get the
word
no battalion sized operations are to
take place in the city
that's what word comes down okay so we
change our battle plan a little bit the
the first the 506 makes it change their
battle plan and they do like a two
company plus
sized operation which which is
pretty close to a battalion sized
operation and that but that was our
first push into
in in in to start establishing we didn't
establish a cop on that but that was the
first hey we're going to come and we're
going to stay
that one was only going to be staying
for a few days but that was a plan of
staying
and then
as far as i'd have to check the dates i
don't remember the dates of when we did
the very first
operation to go and seize ground where
people were gonna stay
but there was
in the time in a couple weeks there was
these
there were some turnover operations that
happened
where we tried to where we being
american coalition forces tried to turn
over certain
certain um
control points out inside the city and
the enemy would attack them and just
cause complete mayhem and they overran
several positions
which again when people ask about what
the enemy was like i was gonna say what
was your sense of them as far as like
how were they as light infantry
they
used
radio communications they had maneuver
elements they would extract their
casualties they would bring in
reinforcements
they they did what a what a military
unit is expected i mean you figure
other than
americans at that point they probably
had more combat experience than just
about any force in the world at the time
for sure and even even americans right
and the 228 when we showed up there had
been on the ground for 14 months but
guess what the people that lived in
ramadi had been in there for
22 years 28 years they'd been in ramadi
since the war started in 2003 so they
had years and years of experience and a
lot of them
were former you know former regime
military personnel so that that helped
as well i was reading a book um i was
talking about the very very early days
of the war and somebody was up in
i think he was what it was is uh we were
basically going around in those early
days looking for a fight looking for
somebody from the iraqi armed forces to
actually stand and fight us but they
were always just melting away melting
away so we said we're going to go after
tikrit that's where saddam's from it's
like the the last place we haven't
really gone into if they're going to
stand and fight anywhere for sure
they're going to stand and fight there
and as journalists i think it was a
dexter filkins book he followed the us
forces into tikrit they just melted away
nobody fought us and we go in there and
he's talking to people iraqis on the
ground with his translator and he finds
a guy who's revolutionary guard and he's
like really wow you're revolutionary
guys like
yeah
so is he he's like really he said yeah
look around it's like that's my buddy
it's such-and-such they're everywhere
right but we don't know who these people
are at this point this is like you know
fall of 2003 maybe late summer
and it almost you know it makes me
wonder if
in a situation like that where even if
you don't necessarily know you're going
to have a big insurgency right
um you know we have like the
general colin powell uh mentality if you
go in with overwhelming force if you
have it available right but in a
situation where the enemy's not going to
stand and fight you like that where just
the presence of your air power alone is
enough for them to be like
hell with this right
is it almost it it's so hard to justify
this politically but if if we were going
to go into iraq
to try to sell it to the american people
here's what we actually need to do we
need to go in there with
80 000 ground troops very limited air
power and challenge these people to a
fight and say come out and fight us
draw them out and make them think like
you know maybe we can actually go out
here and fight these guys in order to
draw them out and fight them
uh because you know in a situation where
everybody just melts into the civilian
population the minute you show up with
you know just a whole core and air power
and everything like that it's really
hard to nail anybody down and then you
end up with an insurgency and it's it i
don't know if it's ever possible to sell
to the american public that we need to
go in here lighter than we actually
could
but
i mean i guess we did it in ramadi
we did do it in ramadi and that's
that's
part of it
i wouldn't say we went in lighter but
here's the deal when you move into
someone's neighborhood
they're either going to fight you or
they're going to leave or they're going
to comply
and so it has the same effect what
doesn't have the effect is hey we're
here where are you they go well we'll
stay until you leave as i said earlier
that we have all the time in the world
you want to hang out here for six months
cool you're american you're going back
to america i live here so
so if you go hey i'm here and i'm gonna
stay that's why putting a timeline on a
war doesn't work
doesn't work because they'll just hold
up for a while and the other thing
that's key to recruiting allies too they
got to know that you're going to stay
because the other people are sure
they're definitely the enemy is
definitely going to stay so if you have
a timeline on the end of your
you know my my fight card expires in 18
months cool 18 months to an insurgent is
a joke right but he's his house yeah
he's in his house it's like it's like
being on you know lockdown oh cool
you're gonna be here for 18 months ago i
can do that i can do hold my breath i'll
go work in my auto mechanic store down
the street i'll make money i'll save up
i'll throw some id's your way
occasionally just to piss you off and
and make sure that you want to leave and
other than that
i'll wait 18 months no factor
yeah
the uh you know the insurgents too it
really adapted to
trying to bring down the institutions
and functioning of civil society right i
mean they they got to the point where
they were killing garbage men they were
killing teachers anybody who was
necessary to make things work yeah and
that's that's a that's a great point to
to bring up and you know there's been a
couple people that have commented uh i
saw on social media
and otherwise about this podcast and you
know of course people were
uh
painting me as sort of pro-american
patriotic
and other completely 100 accurate things
so
i get it
uh one thing though that i see a lot of
is people will say there was x amount of
civilians that were killed in the iraq
war and it's a it's a horrible number
it's a horrible number it's i don't know
if it's in the millions but
it's it's it's i've heard the millions
get thrown around all the time hey
there's civilians there was a millions
of you know whatever that number is
killed during the iraq war and hey if
that number is 10 it's awful if it's
millions it's it's
it's exponentially more awful but it's
the fact of the matter is
those millions
of civilians
were not
killed by american troops were some of
them yes they absolutely some civilians
died at the hands of americans whether
it was um in crossfire whether it was in
errant bomb droppings whether it was in
mistaken identity like hey i say this
all the time if you think you can go
into war and you're going to spare
civilians and they're going to get a get
out of death free card it doesn't happen
civilians are going to die
the
percentage of
iraqi civilians that were killed by
americans
is
minuscule compared to the amount of
iraqi civilians that were killed by
al-qaeda
insert al-qaeda insurgents sunni
insurgents and and shia insurgents like
that's where the killing was now
if you want to take a
if you want to take a very anti-american
stance you can say yeah but those
conditions
that allowed that to happen were because
of
america and to that i'd say yeah well
it's it's tough to argue about that and
we could have done some things better to
pro to prevent that from happening
absolutely and i'm you know looking back
hindsight's 20 20. here's some things
that we would have done different we
already covered some of them you know
let the let the military stay intact
there's a bunch of like the iraqi
military i think we bear some
responsibility i mean not
fully we didn't kill those people but
you know a lot of the
the fact is there was a state structure
intact and we destroyed the state
structure without having a plan in place
we bear some responsibility for what
happened after that the same way as uh
you know you what you'll hear
what you you have an overcrowded uh
military prison or something and the
place runs out of food and they're
starving
you're not killing those people you're
not putting them in gas ovens or
something like that but you're
responsible for you know what's going on
there to you know to a degree yeah and
what you really to take your metaphor
make it even more accurate is
let's say there's a prison a military
prison and it's overcrowded and there's
not much food
and look
but then what happens is now there's a
riot and they kill each other right
because that's what happened that's
basically what happened in iraq that's a
more accurate picture hey there's not
much food there's not much water we're
not just dying of starvation what they
do is they start killing each other
so
that being said
um
when
sure america can take ownership of that
the people that are out there
cutting off
each other's heads
they have to bear some responsibility
too i would say it's 90 10 sure yeah um
but as an american i don't take it like
i don't mind bearing some of that
responsibility you know on our side and
i think uh you know a lot of the
decisions that we talked about in the
first few episodes that were that were
ended up being very bad decisions things
that are going to be lessons learned for
the next hundred years in the american
military hopefully
um
were kind of made because we were
imposing a certain view of how society
works kind of a naive view of how human
groups work as we went in and ramadi
kind of represents the point where we
started to say we got to work with this
country as it is yeah you know
i just released a heavy sigh which also
people commented about they said
whenever i disagree with you i sigh
heavily and actually it's not that i
disagree with you sometimes it's i'm
actually in agreement with you
and i just
just uh
have
additional information about whatever it
is that you just said so some of those
things that
that when we watch them unfold and we
think well we could have done this
different we could have got done that
different
there certainly was things
you know that that if we could go back
we do them different
no doubt
in
like so let me
put it this way actually like um
when we think of how
government works how civil society works
here in america we think of something
like um
what tribal patronage systems like they
have on iraq to us that's corruption
that's nepotism that should be illegal
right you have a whole social system
that's built on this kind of stuff out
there and you guys finally went into
ramadi and said you know we need to
we need to deal with this society as it
is if we're ever actually gonna have a
chance to win in this war
this is you're making a statement that's
accurate it's completely accurate and i
have some examples for you number one
when we got to ramadi some of the
elements some of the iraqi army units
that we were working with
they
we the guys that turned over with us
they're like hey listen there's a real
problem with these this iraqi army unit
okay what's the problem the
officers are skimming pay from the
enlisted guys they're taking some of
their money every month
so we you know well that's a travesty
and we need to fix this
we started pulling that thread
and our you know some of our
interpreters who were either of iraqi
descent or you know or other other
countries over there but had spent time
they're like yeah uh hey joko
that's the way the world works here
you're the boss man your guys get paid
money you take your cut
there's no one look they're gonna
complain about it sure but this is a
cultural thing that we're not gonna
change so that was a big one the whole
way that we went about gathering
intelligence and actioning intelligence
when we started letting those guys kind
of take lead and figure out how they
wanted to do it
in their own way
all of a sudden we started getting much
much better results from them
and then you can carry that all the way
up the chain of command i think that's
actually what my original sigh was about
when you told when you said hey they're
they're a different culture
and when we try and impose our culture
on them it's not going to match up it's
just not gonna match up and you can get
some of it you can force it you can
force something to match up here and
there
but you're not gonna get it to align 100
then you've got to ask where you're
going to focus your efforts because if
i'm
trying to get this iraqi army unit to be
able to
handle security in their own country and
i waste a bunch of time and piss off the
officers because i'm
inciting a mutiny from their troops
because that guy's taking a pay cut
which is what happened to him when he
was a young guy in the army and that's
just the way things are
then you're going to waste your time
doing a lot of things that you shouldn't
be wasting your time
they weren't going to be on time for
some stuff
they were going to say yes to things
that they couldn't support you know that
was kind of a cultural thing that i had
to learn you you might say to you know
an iraqi platoon commander hey can you
have
30 guys for this operation and he's
going to say yep we are you know he's
what he's really going to say is
inshallah you know god willing but he's
nodding his head yes that doesn't that
doesn't mean yes it just means
if god willing we will
so you can't plan on god's will you need
to plan with the numbers that you are
actually going to have so yes we spent a
lot of time
as a country and i i think
you know my vision well my attitude my
mentality was to not
i think it's sort of a jiu jitsu
mentality right hey these guys don't
want to do this but they want to do that
and it looks like it's pretty close i'm
good let's roll with it that is a having
an open mind is very important thinking
that you're going to train
an iraqi soldier to
think
operate and believe
the same as an american soldier is not
is not accurate and the thinking that
their platoon is going to function the
same way that a seal platoon is going to
function or that an assault force
thinking that you're going to be able to
teach them and have them buy into
decentralized command out of the gate
it's going to take a long you can't just
expect them to do decentralized command
when they have been living under a
centralized regime from the top down
where you can be beheaded for making a
mistake they're not super open to
decentralized command so you have to
work with the leadership a little bit
more to start to
e a
move in that direction but more
important b how do we take what your
culture is
and how do we make it work
and that's a very important lesson to
learn about any insurgency and working
with people from other cultures you
you're not gonna well you can change
people's cultures but it takes
generations it's not going to happen in
three months it's not going to happen in
six months not going to happen in a year
it's going to take a long time and it's
going to take
deep
it's going to take deep effort and it's
going to be costly
but
you know we were able to change the
culture of imperial japan they changed
their culture the culture and not all of
it but that you know yes we did change
some of it we we sure as hell didn't
change all of it i mean japan still has
a culture that is rooted the same you
could you could trace threads of the
japanese culture that exists today all
the way back through world war ii to all
the way back to the samurai days you can
do that no problem
so thinking that you're going to change
a culture during a six-month deployment
in a sealed task unit
not a good not a good place to put your
effort what you can do is look at the
culture
see how it operates and see how you can
get to the end state you want
and just like decentralized command hey
look here's what we want to get done i'm
not i'm not too concerned about how we
get there i just want to get there in
japan at least we had a
long-running national identity and
culture we could work with where
you know the over the elites in japan
the bureaucracy that more or less stayed
intact over the course of our conquest
of the islands like you know you could
make changes at the top and it kind of
trickled down
the state had been in place for a long
time and japanese identity and culture
had been in place for a long time you're
dealing with a place over here where
that is not really in existence
especially out in the you know out in
anbar and eastern syria and the desert
there
you know i sent you a quote um as we
were leading up to this episode from a
book where a guy a journalist was over
in the middle east and he had a
jordanian driver an interpreter and this
jordanian is from oman he loves the king
over there he loves him specifically
because he's such a modernizer and a
liberal and this guy is very proud that
jordan is the most western of all the
arab countries
and then this journalist got surprised
because he said as i'm talking to this
guy
the most cosmopolitan guy you can
imagine like from from jordan and he
said uh they're talking about tribal
dynamics and arab countries and how it
makes it harder to kind of form up state
structures and overall national
identities and he said yeah it's
terrible and he said i'm not proud to
say this but
you know if it came down to it and my
tribe went against the king i love the
king but
i'm going with my tribe that's just he
said it's not even a matter of choice so
just of course i would do that this is a
guy who loved the king loved the you
know the country of jordan so you're
dealing with people who are much more
disconnected from
this fledgling little you know part
thing we're calling iraq you know post
circa 2006.
i mean how what was he when you guys
started
going to the tribal leaders
that summer i guess probably start
talking to him yes and what was their
initial reaction i mean had to have been
skepticism at first
uh absolutely and
there's
well first of all say this there's a
when i was off the coast of somalia in
like
94 and we were standing by to go help
but so we were it was it was the closest
i'd ever been to doing something for
real we had our gear loaded we had
operational plans we had briefed our
plans we had our magazines loaded we
were on standby
and we sort of obviously we had done a
lot of intel briefing and one of the
things that i will always remember is
they had this saying that they told us
to try and explain to us what we were
dealing with that there was a somali
saying at least i think it's small it
might it might just be that region
but it was me against my brother
yeah me and my brother against my family
my family against my tribe my tribe
against
somalia somali against the world so so
you have that kind of thing and i've
always said that that's very much like a
seal a sealed team which is me and my me
against my swim buddy
me my swim buddy against my fire team
my fire team against my squad my squad
against my platoon my platoon against
the world or my platoon against my task
unit my task unit against my team my
team against the world so they they
absolutely have that and it is a
it is a
deep
cultural identity that you are part of
this tribe i mean whole empires have
come and gone yes millennia and their
tribal identities have stayed intact
that's gotten them through you know i
mean and it's probably one of the
reasons that the jihadists are so
effective in these areas is the
jihadists actually have
at least it's an ethos they have an
overarching
uh
you know kind of cause that unites them
all together and they don't have all
these little i mean well that's not true
they have plenty of internecine
conflicts and everything but you know
they do have an overarching ideology
it's bringing together like a larger
group of people
and when they're going against tribes
they can you know the thing about tribes
like you said me against my brother and
so on that's a lot of little
uh lines of approach that you can go in
to drive little wedges and break things
apart and
um
i mean so yeah you said i asked you um
if they were skeptical when you first
showed up i mean especially of the idea
that we were going to stick around i
mean they had to have been like
they had to have been skeptical so after
what they'd suffered recently
so i had a god so for the couple things
here first of all there is violent
battles happening every day and every
night in ramadi
violent there's 30 to 50 enemy attacks a
day many of these attacks are
dynamic
complex attacks from you know with
multiple units enemy units attacking
strong points the government centered in
downtown ramadi which
the marines that were down there were
just heroic
out there for months on end and that
place would get attacked all the time i
could see we could see from the rooftop
of my building which was on the other
side of the euphrates river you could
see
these firefights taking place in all
over downtown ramadi all the time so
this is completely violent so all the
residents can hear it probably is going
on it's not a huge city right so no it's
only like few hundred
three three or four miles across from
one so yes you can so they're hiding in
their houses listen to gun battles
tracer fires everywhere it's
it it's it's like that right so this
idea
for me so i've got various lines of
operation that i'm supposed to be
conducting i'm supposed to be you know
doing the hearts and minds thing i'm
supposed to be doing um civil affairs so
out building i'm supposed to be doing
direct action missions to get rid of bad
guys
and the one that i kind of added was
like hey we're going to support and do
these overwatch positions and one of the
lines of operation was tribal engagement
t e tribal engagement go out and meet
the tribes
so i'm looking at this and i'm a i'm
trying to be a good seal trying to be
trying to carry my
load
and
i'm supposed to assign a small element
of seals to be in charge of tribal
engagement
i don't have the manpower to do it
i don't know i can't who am i going to
take one of my one of my combat leaders
that's out running operations that's out
you know leading troops i'm going to
take one of my senior enlisted guys that
is making tactical calls on the
battlefield
so i'm not gonna sacrifice and by the
way from a prioritize and execute
standpoint we aren't even close to
making these people feel like we're
they're safe and secure so this is no
time to say all right i'm gonna
take away my firepower which is in
support of these massive operations that
are now happening and i'm gonna instead
assign seals to do tribal engagement
but i still needed to do tribal
engagement i happen to have a guy
who was
and i and i believe
you might know this he's a fleet navy
guy he's a prior enlisted guy and his
his officer
specialty his mos was like information
operations or something like that it
wasn't psyops but
i forget what it actually was but he's
not a seal
he's a
and i
someday i'm sure i'll have him on the
podcast because i'm sure it'd be great
to hear this from his perspective
because you got a picture this guy is a
regular fleet navy guy he shows up he's
part of my so the task unit is made up
of
depending on when and where there's
between 35 and 45 seals the other
people the other
60 or 70 people that bring this task
unit up to 100 people is all support
people so radio men and weapons guys and
a bunch of seabees
and then i got this random kind of
information operations officer
i don't remember what his actual job was
and he is a he's a really nice guy he's
tall which and i just remember he's tall
because when you see people getting into
humvee they're tall it's kind of it's
kind of awkward
he has very limited combat training
he'd probably done some some training
before we deployed you know hey sight in
your weapon
learn some basic medical stuff but but
but very untrained
and so i'm looking at him and he's also
interestingly enough he's married to
i want to say he's married to a japanese
woman
and he's uh because i think he was maybe
stationed in japan mary's a japanese
woman and he's a buddhist so he's a
buddhist and he's a he's a like a white
guy from from ohio or something really
nice guy
so i said hey here's what's going on man
i said
and i you know i called him by his first
name but i'll just call him jg for now
because that's you know he was a
lieutenant jg so i go hey jg
this is what's going on man we got these
tribes out here and
we want to get them on our side and we
want to talk to them i want you to start
going out with the army when they go out
and start trying to talk to some of
these tribal leaders and he's like yeah
yes sir
so he starts going out and i'm not
thinking too much of it at the time not
thinking very much of it
and he's so he starts going out and and
again you see this guy he's got like you
know the the stereotypical brand new web
gear you know his weapon
he looks uncomfortable holding it and
and by the way
he's going out on ied laden streets like
he is taking a massive risk of being
blown up and killed
you know one of the groups that he was
going out with though i think it was the
in their first 36 hours on the ground
they took mass casualties i think they
lost five soldiers to a couple ieds i
mean these guys are hanging it out there
and so he's going with these guys so
when i'm
when i'm uh jesting a little bit about
the way he looked don't don't mistake
that for me questioning his courage in
any way shape or form because he was
loading up and going out into these
unknown neighborhoods
trying to interact with these
with the tribes
so that is
that is where this tribal engagement
began for me i'm not giving anyone up
if you know how to shoot a machine gun
well you're going to shoot machine guns
who do i got that i can send to talk to
tribes hey how about a how about a prior
enlisted
lieutenant jg information operations
buddhist yeah that way when they say
crusader americans you'd be like
crusader's got nothing to do with me man
so
he starts going out and he comes back
from one of these operations
and he says hey i i think i i think i
got something for you and i said well
what do you got he says i met this guy
today
and he says he wants to be part of
desert protector
and
i said okay and desert so so desert
protector was a program
and and i really hope that i'm
remembering this right and for anyone
that i messed this up please just let me
know and i'm sorry
when the marine corps pushed through
al-qaeda
they as they moved from building to
building
some of the locals
started saying hey marine over there in
that building down the street there's a
bunch of bad guys in there you should go
kill them and we're just we're just
locals and we live here but there's bad
guys over there and they'd go check it
out guess what there's bad guys
and so
what whatever marine element was in
charge and i apologize for not being
able to give them the credit by name but
they said wait a second there's a bunch
of local people that don't want al qaeda
here maybe we should join forces with
them maybe we should help them maybe
they can help us
so they started this program called
desert protector which was hey we'll
help you get arms we'll you know we'll
work together
and we'll start cleaning up the desert
getting rid of all these bad guys
well
when maliki so these are all sunni
tribes now the sunni tribal leaders that
are like okay cool you're gonna give us
guns and ammo and and we'll help you and
we'll get rid of these people that are
trying to terrorize us awesome
so we
they start this desert protector program
so this and you know i just had read
about this from after actions report
that's how i knew about it so jg comes
back to me
this makes me want to get jg on the
pajama podcast to hear his side of the
story because can you imagine what he
was thinking
he comes back to me it takes a certain
kind of personality to be able to do
something like that yeah and the good
thing is is he was older you know he was
he was a jgb he was a prior enlisted guy
so he was like we were probably about
the same age so we we we
you know we had a good very good
relationship
so he comes back to me he's like hey
jocko i
i think i got somebody for you and he
met this guy it was shakes it ended up
being a guy named shakes at arbazia
which the name meant nothing to me when
i heard it he said i met this shake he
wants to be a part of desert protector
and i said
okay
desert protector when maliki
the shia had been elected
he looked out west and said wait a
second we got these desert protectors
that's a bunch of sunni militias running
around the country out of my control
maybe not out of control but definitely
not in my control we and he disbanded
the program stopped him so now desert
protector's gone now
rewind we just had the glass factory
bull open january which meant we had no
iraqi police but
the iraqi police were was what was going
to be a government organization that
would be supported by the iraqi
government that was blessed by the iraqi
government to help fight the insurgents
so i said to jg
i said well desert protector is done
it's been canceled
i said i'll tell you what go back and
tell him that the new desert protector
program is called the iraqi police
and if he wants to get his troops and
his tribesmen to join the iraqi police
we'll give them training we'll give them
ammunition we'll give them weapons
and we'll give them uniforms
i said because also tell him that if
he's got his guys running around in
neighborhoods
with machine guns
and track suits on we're we will kill
them
he needs to know that
so jg goes out
comes back and it it may and i wish i
could remember this accurately within
two okay and
so he goes back and and
i get the report back he's in
that's the report he's in
he's in i said okay at that point and we
had been doing this you know holding
hands doing this with the with a with a
conventional force that's who that's who
jg had been going out with and i believe
this was also uh the 136
um
great crew and a guy by the name of
colonel dean
he was with him and so it turned into
okay he said okay to this and i'm like
oh okay
so we ran uh and and this is when we
said okay we've done what we can do
because you know i got 30 seals like we
can't run a big recruiting thing and
we did volunteer to train them though we
said okay if we can get these guys here
we'll train them
get start getting them wearing a similar
uniform and it was so this all happened
and within
a very short period of time
jg went to these one of these meetings
and came back and said hey sir
you know
you can get this translated but this is
a document there's a bunch of tribal
leaders that are going to work together
with us
and that was that was what became known
as the the ambassador for everybody out
there that doesn't know this this guy's
satar this tribal leader is a younger
guy
he's one of the guys that came up after
you know the the godfathers all got
wiped out the year before i mean this is
the central guy who got all the tribes
together and
kicked off the ambar awakening he was he
was uh
very
pro-american we were after him like the
year before right and the year before we
had got like actually the not even a
year the task unit before us
had taught we had a target package on
this guy meaning this guy's a bad guy
and we need to go get him
so we had a target package on him why
would why was he a bad guy why did they
consider him a bad guy because he was
running guns because he was a gangster
and how do you become a how do you
maintain your position as a shake how do
you get money is that you need money you
need power how do you do that well it
looks like smuggling is going to work
right now cool we're smuggling that's
what he's doing smuggling guns and
making things happen
and we immediately obviously pulled him
from the target it's like okay this
guy's on board and this goes back to the
quote that i talked about on one of the
earlier podcasts of
the we're going to vote we're going to
we're going to bet on the winning horse
so that's what he kind of did he said
okay here's the winning horse and and uh
general mcfarland who's a colonel at the
time went through the same thing with
his chain of command they said what are
you talking about this guy is going to
lead a coalition we have a target
package on this guy and he he he was
telling the story
colonel mcfarland you know he's he was
telling the story you know at the at the
table at the table for
for at one of these brigade meetings
he's telling the story this
you know to have lived through this i'm
so lucky to have been sitting at these
tables and sitting at these meetings and
no seeing this stuff unfold but he's
sitting at this meeting and you know he
says you know the the generals wondering
why we're going to work with a guy
that's
that that we were targeting
and that has run guns and is a smuggler
and you know what i and and the colonel
said you know i told him hey boss
the guy is a mobster he's a gangster
that's what gangsters do and now he
wants to work with us and we need to we
need to move forward and you know he
convinced him because that's what we
ended up doing even if you think about
what we mean by a mobster when we think
of the mob we think of the italian mob
the irish mob the jewish mob ethnic
mafias right these groups that come over
here that have some external reason to
be tight-knit you know they're all from
sicily or they got the family whatever
it is
and again we've got a society over here
that we've got bureaucratized and kind
of all the rules are in place and
anybody that's doing anything kind of
off the grid that's a criminal activity
that's corruption or whatever
that's something that we've worked
through only over time though and
there's a lot of little more local
informal ways of social you know means
of social regulation that are still at
play in tribal societies like that you
think about something like in the u.s
where
if you have a
let's say uh
the the truck drivers union or this you
know the longshoremen's union right and
back in the day like a couple cases of
stakes and a couple cases of whiskey you
would go missing off the docks or
whatever
and we've got all these things in place
now to make sure that doesn't happen
everything is stamped and tracked with
rfid chips and blah blah blah blah and i
suppose that's fine it's more efficient
there's you know
it's not that you should be able to
steal things but if you think about
the little the the the more local level
things that that used to facilitate a
guy's not taking those things home and
eating them all himself right those
things are a barbecue is gonna be given
at the union hall for all the union guys
and he's gonna go to one of the local
restaurants it's not some big chain and
give them a discount on some of the uh
stuff that he took off of there and it's
kind of it's providing these little
sinews in that local community and
making things work and
giving that guy
what they call an iraq wasta right he's
got that he's got the juice now which
means it what it does is now if he's
just a wild criminal that's not a good
thing
but it does mean that you got somebody
to go to if you need to who has some
authority who has some juice in a
community
and you know again in america we just
don't think of things like that
everything's corporatized and
bureaucratized and we don't we look at
those things as almost an unnatural
outgrowth when that's the natural state
of things you know we've got this like
very complex machine put together
together over here
everything's handled much more local and
formally over there and you know you
guys had to start learning how to think
like that and learning how to work with
that yeah
here's an example and i'm so glad you
brought this up
so we got a guy that's a gangster
he was running guns and doing whatever
he was doing maybe he was even
conducting or directing attacks against
coalition forces i don't know that i
don't really think so this guy had this
guy had
his house kind of looked like the white
house
purposefully i want to say he had us i
want to say he had a life-size picture
of john wayne
uh in his in his house i think i've read
that yeah i think i'm pretty so so he's
a real
like he's a courageous guy too they
murdered um
his brother ran off his brother ran off
but you know his grandfather was like
one of the people that led his
grandfather led rebellions against the
british
right this guy
he's
he's he's a guy that
he's not playing around you know he's a
he's a gangster he's a tough guy but
he's he's very pro coalition at this
point
and so one of the things that i did
is we had uh you know i mentioned that
we were supposed to do civil affairs
so we start giving this guy civil
affairs projects
and what does that mean that that means
we're giving him money and distribution
so so i remember we did some project
with him and it was
it was a really big summer one i was i
want to say it was 150 000
150 000
it was a road pavement or whatever
something like that
and and and again i i
remember i don't want to say i got
pushback
but
i got some questions about like hey who
you know is it really worth 150 000 to
pave this road and couldn't the
engineers do it and so you know along
that line of questioning yeah and i was
like no this is money to prop this to
give this to prop this guy up but more
importantly to give this guy wasta to
give this guy hey he's going to feed
that hundred and fifty thousand dollars
you know he's gonna buy
iraqi army are getting like 300 bucks a
month at the time he's gonna buy two
thousand dollars worth of worth of uh uh
uh stuff to repair the road
and then the rest of that money is gonna
pay his people and he's gonna he's gonna
gain wasa and that's the kind of thing
where that
where
it really helped it made him more
powerful and
which is what we wanted because
other people see it you hook up with the
americans
and this guy
the cool thing was and the point i want
to make clear here
this guy wasn't like some puppet this
guy wasn't some
you know
this guy we didn't insert america didn't
this guy's not a manchurian candidate
that we put in here hey here's here's a
guy no this guy is
from ramadi he grew up there his family
is rooted there this is what this is his
world
and he's not a plant he's not some
person that america is using as a puppet
no he's a guy that is gonna be powerful
in this part of iraq and he's not
following american orders what he's
doing is he's trying to build his
country back so i just want to make sure
that that is clear because i could see
people thinking oh they just got some
shill to throw in there no no no this
guy a tribal leader
is almost a sovereign entity
absolutely absolutely this and you can't
you can't just insert a tribal leader it
doesn't work because everything's built
on legitimacy when it comes to the
tribes and i also have to say this
when you want people to bet on the
winning horse
you have to be the winning horse and one
of the things that
that took place
that
allowed these tribal leaders to come on
board was they started to see that we
were going to win
they started to see that we were going
to win
and you know i i
had many
conversations when we got home from
ramadi about this
and
one of the things that i would say is
that these these the hearts and minds
and the civil affairs operations
those things can only take place
after the sword
has been
unleashed
and the enemy realizes
that we will defeat them but more
importantly
the local populace realizes that we will
defeat the enemy that's what allows
why would you look you're you're in a
lifeboat that's sinking and there's two
boats you can get on
one of them it has a leak in it the
other one looks like it's going strong
which one are you gonna get in
so you what you have to do is you have
to go to that other boat you have to put
us you have to hack at it until it's
gonna go down and then the people are
gonna get inside your boat and that's
this is a classic example of what
happened and you know it's interesting i
was talking to lathe the other day
when we got done with this
leif went and took over the junior
officer training course
and for seals so the young seals are
coming through this course and one of
the things that they had to do was they
they get different people come and talk
about different conflicts and they
wanted someone to talk about counter
insurgency
and you know life was
up his chain of command said hey you
know i i can talk about the
counterinsurgency if you want we can
talk about the battle of ramadi and
they're kind of
you know life's a young lieutenant and
and and
you know
just from ramadi and it's almost like oh
yeah i i get it you want to tell your
story but you know we need to get a
counter insurgency we need to get
someone that's got a little bit more
experience
and the i guess it was and again i'm
sorry if i'm telling this wrong but it's
something close
the officer in charge the overall guy
was like you know what we're going to
get a green beret because that's sort of
the green beret's
bread and butter right the bread and
butter of the green berets is
counterinsurgency you know that's what
they base their training on
and and so he wanted to get a green
beret to come to the junior officer
training course and teach
teach counterinsurgency so they finally
find a green beret
and the green beret comes and i i think
he actually ended up working there
and so
leif you know comes into his
counterinsurgency class
and the guy teaches
the battle of ramadi and said this is
the best example that we have of a
counterinsurgency is what happened in
the battle of ramadi
and
as this progressed
you know this this as this was all
taking place
this this sort of tribal engagement
again in all the different lines of
operation so as this is taking place
this is sort of
it's sort of an
uh a
a slow cooker that's happening
because in the front front line and
front and center of this whole thing
there was
sustained urban combat operations that
were happening all over the city of time
oh yeah you had to put them on their
back foot i mean did you start to notice
like
was there something that lets you know
you were making progress like a decrease
in the complexity of enemy attacks or
this is what made it so hard was
at first
for months
you're not
you're not feeling the progress you can
hear about it a little bit so the
closest thing i would say was we would
get the intel from the shakes and their
tribesmen like that progress was being
made that bad guys were leaving that you
know
um
they the the
tribesmen would conduct operations we'd
hear about that they'd be like oh we
killed these guys and it would get
reported up the chain of command as a as
a red on red they'd call it meaning oh
there's infighting between tribes and
we'd be going no it's not that's not red
on red that's good guys that's good guys
that's our people
out there killing bad guys so we got so
that would it there was no who are you
getting those like that word from who
was calling it red on red like what
level were you thinking you know
i i would have to dig in but at some
point you know you'd get a report back
that there was a red on red killing
between this tribe and that tribe and
you'd be like no i wasn't between two
tribes that was between this tribe that
we know that's on board and a bunch of
bad guys and that's what just happened
and so you know we'd try and clarify it
they'd understand but
but so we'd start to hear that but there
was no discernible
reduction in the level of violence
for the first
i mean it was like five out of six i
mean actually and i don't even know if
at the end it look it just didn't it
didn't get better it really didn't get
better there was there was one the last
operation the last big combat outpost
that we put in
we put in in right in the middle of
ramadi and when we put that
when we put that um last combat outpost
and i win i remember i actually have a
picture there's i think it might be in
one of these books the picture of myself
and general mcf or colonel mcfarland at
the time standing in this combat outpost
and it was
smack dab in the middle of ramadi
and i had actually i think i actually
cleared this with a couple army guys
and as the as a platoon guys late
splatoon was out setting up some
overwatch positions the overwatch was
normally in these situations there would
be just
you know
leif and his guys would probably kill
you know between five and 20 bad guys
and on this particular last one that we
did there was no there was no bad guys
killed now
this is by no stretch meaning that it's
over because it was hard fighting that
was going to happen but if you had to
ask me if there was anything where oh
there's less violence that was that was
the first indication that we got that
maybe
things might get better here
but
you know that was you know we were we
were fighting and and you know mikey
mikey monsoor
um you know that he he was killed on
september 29th and so
that's you know we're weeks from going
home at that point and believe me that
whole that that that day was a fight and
so
there was no real discernible and that's
one of the things there's no real
discernible reduction in the level of
violence
but when we got home
that's when we that's when it's changed
and it changed so dramatically it was
hard to believe i remember there was the
sofia incident i think it was sophia
right in december when there was one of
the holdout tribes that had been slow to
come over to our side and he came under
attack by al qaeda a big massive attack
at mcfarland general mcfarland made the
decision he's not technically on our
side yet let's go back him up
and that was in december right and then
after that it was like the tide broke
it's
that's a classic example of
you know just great leadership from
general mcfarland right hey this guy's
been causing us problems but now we can
help him
and let's see what that gets us for
loyalty in the long run and what do we
have to lose well if he
he hates us he or he's he doesn't like
us now if we help him and he still
doesn't like us okay we're still where
we're at but if we help him and he likes
us well then maybe we've made some maybe
we've made some progress yeah i mean by
i think you got articles from people who
were who were there visiting journalists
who were there visiting in early 06
spring of 06 right around the time you
were getting there
who came back a year later in the summer
of 07 and they said american soldiers
are walking around
with no body armor in the middle of town
there's markets open and it's just
it's crazy to me
the courage of the iraqis who actually
went out there and opened their
businesses again and got their lives
going blows me away
and it just shows you how how quickly
things can change you know once people
and and how quickly people can adapt to
a situation once they feel safe and once
they feel like there's something to look
forward to tomorrow
and that's why that tentative counter
insurgency is security of the populace
security for the populist is so
important because until they have that
they're going to hole up they're going
to give passive support to whoever they
think is going to not kill them which it
doesn't take long to feel it doesn't
take long to figure out that the
americans are not going to kill you but
the insurgents will so who are going to
help you're going to help the people
that will kill you if you don't help
them and and that's
it's it's it's horrible and that's why
the sword of
destruction has to be wielded with a
heavy hand
when you show up there against those
insurgents and at the same time it has
to be wielded with an accurate hand
because if you when you kill civilians
even unintentionally it still it can
cause backlash now i'll be perfectly
frank with you and say that these people
have been at war for so long
that they actually understood you know
they they actually would understand when
something bad happened they they would
understand and they wanted us to be
there you know there was um
i guess i would say
there was you know like guys would
always come back oh yeah there was
people cheering
when we
when we killed these bad guys and that
was um
i think that was powerful
yeah it was powerful um
we got to wrap this up there's one thing
i want to leave us with
there's this quote from an army first
lieutenant
in one of rick's books
he's talking about this period it was
right about this period that he made
this quote he said uh that all the
shiites have to do is tell everyone to
lay low wait for the americans to leave
and then when they leave you have a
target list and within a day they'll
kill every sunni leader in the country
there's an argument or is there
maybe we'll cover this more as we go to
the next episode but something to leave
you with is
were we
there's some people that say by arming
the sunni tribes calm the iraqi police
if we want to tell them they're only
going to operate in their own little
areas however we handle it
that we were trading
we were getting we were gaining
short-term security and but planting the
seeds for like longer term instability
because there's no way that the shield
were ever going to be okay with that
no well
let me say this
when you take
the people of ramadi
from a vicious war-torn situation
and you put them in a scenario
where there's peace
and there's prosperity
people
get
i'll use the word addicted
right when life is good people start
saying wow
we don't have to live the way we used to
live
and when when i came home
and saw
that there had been success because like
i said we didn't get to see it with our
own eyes
but when i came home
and saw that
the markets were open
and there was kids playing in the
streets and there was kids playing
soccer and there was girl school girls
being taught
and that there was peace and prosperity
when i saw that
[Music]
two things
number one
the sacrifices that were made
by
the
first off the american troops because
it's not it's not our country they're
going over there and doing it
it's it's a hundred percent sacrifice so
the guys yeah the guys from task unit
bruiser
knowing that their sacrifice that they
made that they sacrificed their lives
that there was an absolute victory there
knowing the
army soldiers the marines that laid down
their lives to try and protect that
civilian populace
and and just knowing this i mean every
every you know when you when you're
walking around with with these soldiers
with these marines with your own guys
and and they get killed you know that
every one of those individuals that gets
killed is a [__] travesty it's a
travesty
and
there's you know from from our time
period there there was
you know uh
in the for the one one a d was like a
hundred a hundred soldiers kill for the
two two eight it was about the same so
every one of these guys is a travesty
the the the
only thing that can make you feel better
is when you look and you say you know
what
those sacrifices that were made
look at these kids playing soccer look
at this young girl going to school and
being educated look at this family being
able to live in peace
so that's part one
part two is
when you see it
when we got sent pictures home from what
ramadi was like and you'd see it on cnn
or you see it on the news you'd see what
was happening
the other thing i would think to myself
is
this might work
this
this i i actually thought this will work
this that's what i started thinking this
is going to work because these people
that live there look we've they've now
shown that they had the kind of grit to
stand up and fight
and and not so much you know the iraqi
army yes a little bit but the local
populace that they if they got together
they would stand up and they weren't
going to put up with these insurgents
and that meant
this could work and i thought you know
what who's going to a lot look like i
said sheikh satar bazia
he's a gangster he's a badass
and if he's there he's not going to let
this happen again
why would they and now we've got all
these tribal guys working together why
would they ever let their their now
prosperous sit and peaceful city why
would they ever let it slide back i
think
[Music]
we're going to win and by we i mean i
think the iraqi people are going to win
and be
i think it's going to work
and so those two things
knowing the sacrifices and then seeing
the results was what was the you know it
was
so it was enough to convince a critical
mass of people in the american
government that it could work i mean
because we were on our way out the door
with our tail between our legs when you
guys went into ramadi and by the end of
it the people who were saying this is a
winnable fight you know had enough juice
in the government the bush
administration to push that argument and
they got their chance after the 06
election to you know we got the surge in
o7 i mean
it's not an exaggeration to say that i
mean all of that was riding on the
outcome of ramadi
yes had we lost ramadi
in that we there's no way anything else
would have happened there's no way the
surge would have happened absolutely and
the surge really was enough to to
was a good tipping point to start really
moving the rest of the country in the
right direction with the same type of
strategy that was used in ramadi we're
not going to do drive-by you know
counter-insurgency we're going to get in
there we're going to take control we're
going to show that we're going to
protect the local populace
and then here
well
i'm sure we'll get into it next time but
you know when a plant when a tree first
starts to grow
its roots aren't very deep and it
doesn't take much of a wind storm or
much rain to
uproot that thing and send it down the
river
and
although this
this tree was
looking green and was starting to grow
roots it wasn't there yet
probably a good time to wrap it up for
this one um
if you're listening to this podcast
then
well we appreciate you listening to it
you can also check out our other
podcasts
i got a podcast called jocko podcast
got a podcast called the warrior kid
podcast and i got a podcast called
grounded
daryl has got a podcast called martyr
made
you can support all these podcasts by
getting some gear from jocko's store or
origin main so jackostore.com or
originmaine.com i also have a consulting
company
it's called echelonfront.com
we help people learn leadership
and align leadership inside companies
and with that
thanks for listening
as things
unravel
this is jocko and daryl
out